why do you feel that if that if that guy
likes
why don't they like why why would you
say that they don't okay so
vulnerability once again is something
that guys over emphasize it's very
similar to what i was saying here they
overemphasize vulnerability but you said
they don't like it very specifically
women yeah women do not like they don't
because okay so i'm telling you they do
okay what they've done and i'm telling
you they don't because
because since
the uh the sexual revolution we have and
you'll probably understand this is since
the sexual evolution we have
systematically tried to feminize men
from like say the boomer generation up
to the gen x and up to where we're at
right now so what's the number one
message that we tell them be more
emotional get in touch with your
feminine side be more like feminized men
and masculinize women part of that
social engineering
project that's been going on experiment
really since like 1965 part of that is
get in touch with your emotions express
yourself emotionally be more to be a
more well-rounded perfect man is to be
more like a woman and that's why i'm
saying well you understand though
there's a big space a whole lot of space
between a feminized man which i don't
think most women want and a man who's
willing to share vulnerabilities okay
there's there's a big space in there and
i there's a big difference between a guy
i mean i don't think you want to turn on
the notebook every night and have your
husband cry top to bottom no i don't but
you know if you watch that movie and
there was a moment where your husband
shared for example hey you know i lost a
family member to alzheimer's and that
was really hard for me and told that
story that is a vulnerability
but
that is something that that's not game
that's not building up that's not
building equity that's building the
relationship for sure now here's my
other point it's building equity well
here let me explain something to you so
when we're when i talk about
vulnerability especially when it comes
to like we were just talking about uh
you know revealing your notch count and
everything that comes from guys thinking
that to get to sex
means that they have to be vulnerable
they have to be emotionally available
they have to be comfortable they have to
have everything on the table they have
to be in a completely open book and
usually what happens is women get bored
of that they're looking for a guy who's
exciting who's fun who wants to go
skydiving wants the the date to end up
being something that seems almost
dangerous
and like as i was saying before now for
longevity though okay but we're talking
about in the initials in the end well in
the initial stages i mean sure if you if
you show up crying every day all day
something that brings that
but you can be you can do it all
you can be all of that that that's what
i was hoping that your message would be
to men you can be all of that you can be
a a masculine man you can you know be
proud of your physique you can
care about health and wellness you can
have a career that you're passionate
about you can have a woman beside you
that you love and respect
you can do all of that you can also
share your emotions you can say i love
you you can say i lost a family member
five years ago and this is once you're
in the relationship
okay so you're talking again before you
get into the relationship you feel that
vulnerability what i'm saying is that
what i'm saying is that okay so the
definition of vulnerability is weakness
let's start talking about things in
objective terms instead of emotional
terms as i was saying before we live in
the fields before real's generation
right now when you go and you see that
that chick that was uh and before
congress talking about like how we got
to talk about birthing people instead of
women let's just call them women
listen i got real excited i like an aoc
dig role because what we're doing is we
have we're using we're we're speaking
the language of emotionalism when we
need to start getting down to brass
tacks because if we don't we will not
turn i think there's just a balance i
don't think there's a bad okay yes there
is a balance you know what the balance
you know what's completely out of
balance is the fact that we are in the
fields before real's generation right
now and really have been i would i would
argue for the last 20 or 30 years
however
but that is the result of i need to be
more emotional men even more vulnerable
i'm not saying you have to be this
complete doormat simp [ __ ] i'm saying
that by order of degree every generation
we layer another one of those on top of
there to the point where we teach our
boys to be defective girls so you've got
a five-year-old boy who's who is primary
he knows no other way of teaching except
for the women that have been teaching
him since the time he was born all the
way until he gets into postgraduate i
think there is there are people in
society that are agenda driven in the
exact capacity you're talking about i
think that there is an agenda and
oftentimes that comes from modern
feminism and how it has distorted what
actual founding feminism looked like and
has in in the process would you call
yourself a feminist
i would not because i don't like how
that term has been bastardized by the
modern language i think you're a
feminist you don't know it
i don't think so i think modern actually
i should say this and i've made this
here's my bold point is that anyone born
after like 1965 you are a feminist or
you have had feminist indoctrination
like infiltration
believe me my my whole career is going
after this nonsense i don't know how
much you know about my politics but i've
spent a long time defending men i've
spent a long time defending men's honor
i've spent a long time standing up for
people like brett kavanaugh who got you
know criminalized on second one being
with no evidence because he was a guy
me too listen i spent a long time going
after me too and a long time going after
believe her no you need to just get
gather your evidence and then figure out
what's going on don't believe a woman on
on day one because she's a woman so i
spent a long time rallying against this
stuff
so i reject that term i think that
modern feminism now is equated with
hyper promiscuity in women which i don't
think is a good thing i don't think
that's a good direction for women i
think it's also associated with a
pro-abortion movement which i don't
support and i think it really ends there
i don't think it's really about women at
all i don't think it's about female
empowerment as it was once called
but if you're asking me if i believe in
you know equality of opportunity not
equality of outcomes but a quality of
opportunity for men and women 100
percent if you're asking me if i believe
that women should you know be the
authors of the life that they want for
themselves and that i would want that
message to go to a daughter if i had one
110 percent but that should not involve
deflating men there is absolutely no
reason for that and if you're doing that
then you are playing a game and that i
will not endorse in my mind that's not
that doesn't fit
we'll get to feminism a minute let me
just finish up on vulnerability really
quickly now here's the other thing
can vulnerability be sexy in a guy yes
it can if that guy has already
established himself as being sort of an
alpha
for lack of a veteran alpha male a guy
who's a high value guy who is reserved
with his emotions because men are
biologically different from women i
agree with the neurological side i agree
with you a hundred percent
women tend to so like the trying mind
theory is this it's like instinct
emotion and reason for women it's in for
both sexes it's instinct first no matter
what that's just hardwired into it yeah
then there is uh emotion and then
there's reason those are ways of
interpreting our surroundings like well
animals in general but human beings in
particular here and women tend to go
instinctive motion and reason men before
the sexual revolution used to be
instinct reason and then emotion how do
i feel about what just happened after i
interpret and figure out what's going on
here for women it's the other way around
it's instinct how do i feel about this
and then what actually happened and so
there's that difference so men are not
necessarily hardwired to
feel emotion in the same way that a
woman does and that's why i think that
one of the biggest i think that's fair
one of the biggest things that has
happened or one of the the biggest
social engineering experiments that
we've had really in the last like 65
years now is that we have tried to
condition men to to think like women to
to make the the female process the
correct way of thinking so we go
instinct emotion and reasons rather than
instinct reason and then emotion so when
we're looking at
the interpretive processes which ones
are faster instinct is the number one
that's fastest right then there's
emotion how do i feel about this and
then reason takes a lot of time because
you have to learn things you have to you
have to study taekwondo or martial arts
or you gotta yeah you have to learn how
to you know turn the car into the skid
instead of like with this or slam on the
brakes so you die right and it's skit
there's there's aspects of life where we
have to learn unlearn things that we
were never evolved to have you know had
to deal with in the first place but what
we've done is we've uh we've kneecapped
men for the last four generations by
saying you need to think and feel before
you actually you know do anything
rational or reasonable in fact even for
me to say the rational mailer to title
my book or anything they say the
rational mail
why why why is that why is that the
initial response so my response would be
that men should just be human beings you
know well
they are what's a human being well i
think a human being is called matt walsh
on you what's a human being
people are complex you know and i think
that
it's okay i understand what you're
saying that they're people around the
time you follow but you're talking about
timing when you say vulnerability i
think you would be having a very
different conversation about being
vulnerable in some capacity with a wife
or a spouse than you would if you are if
you're with a guy who doesn't share his
emotions very you're attracted to him
you're in a relationship he's not as
emotional as you are he doesn't cry
during titanic or whatever okay like
he's he's just simply he's not a he's
not wired for that and b it's not
because he has some sort of socialized
learning that says yeah oh you got it
men don't cry maybe he does you know
when his dog maybe that's just not who
he is
well or maybe it's that that's just not
who men are because we don't have the
same wiring we don't have the same see
that that ignores the reality that there
are men that are very different i mean i
think men who are much more vulnerable
with their and much they just that's
just who they are they're wired that way
much more so than another conditioned to
be that way they're not wired that way i
i don't know about that again though i
think a lot goes into the way you were
raised show you the fmri studies that
show that exactly was your dad in the
home what was your dad like did you have
a father figure what kind of role did
that play i think all of that comes in
social media but that is a social
constructionism is what that is and we
overly rely on that right now so yeah
i'm not saying that there are actually
genetic reasons why a guy could right
well that could be yeah exactly so there
could be there are differences but my
point is my point is
my point is this is that when a guy is
not as like emotionally available yeah
let's just say because that labor loves
that term right and then but he's strong
you say she's still into him she loves a
guy because he's not that way because
he's stoic and he knows what he's doing
whatever however you want to parse it
out and then his mom dies or then right
his dog dies or
whatever or that he has an emotional
moment and he is vulnerable for that
brief second
that is very sexy for women because that
is the only time that that guy who's
whose character is predominantly defined
by being not as emotional shows some
emotion and she's the only one that can
bring it out and she's the only one that
is there when he's having that yes
absolutely vulnerability can't but
that's the problem every guy goes oh
well if that's sexy then i'm just going
to be as vulnerable as i possibly can
and then more women will like that so
they're not authentic though right so i
think you have to be authentic you have
to be because you are and it's not only
about sexy though men want to out
vulnerable other men they want to go
well if that's sexy then i'm going to be
the goddamn vulnerable
possible not just about sexy i think
sexy is a word that's really hot when
you're first dating someone but when
you're talking about a life partner also
what you really want i don't care you're
a man you're a woman you want a human
being and i know you asked me what that
was before but you want someone who you
can go through the ups and downs of life
with and part of that is really
experiencing things like i don't think
women want someone who's just you know
not emotional at all and then
occasionally so i don't want to marry mr
spock you don't you don't so i think
that that was the new one by the way
that's important i'm trying to find that
impossible
and i'm just trying not to be emotional
at some point right well there are some
men that are very guarded about that for
many reasons um and and consistently
guarded about that and it becomes then a
challenge of like how do i get that
person to open up and that may be
intriguing at first that will be
exhausting very quickly because
ultimately i think what most women want
is someone who is going to sh if you're
going to share a life with me then you
got to share
share with me when you're open
yes right and again the difference
between a guy who cries at titanic and
someone who shares a story about their
past and the reason why i say that
vulnerability is not sexy to women is
when it is overly done overly done okay
again you wear your mouse on your sleeve
right just this okay little wall flap
that's what i'm trying to make there are
qualifiers here though and someone
are by order of degree but listen what
i'm trying to tell you and i hope you
can hear what i'm saying is that someone
you say you're not giving advice right
that's not your goal people are taking
this as advice and someone will walk
away from this and make a decision to
not be vulnerable ever or to not allow
themselves to be a human being who goes
through something maybe they've had
experience with someone so let me maybe
they need that but maybe they don't i am
not in the business of making men better
men i'm in the business of giving men
the tools they need to make themselves
better men i don't want a cult i'm not
saying a qualifier i don't i'm not i'm
not an influencer in the sense that i'm
like yeah i'm not my my goal is not to
have you become a tomasi guy or be in my
cult or be in my i'd be a believer of my
life well that's the law
what my my goal is to put out and give
guys tools i got you so that they can
use those tools to build a better life
maybe those guys need that tool because
they're like i've been vulnerable i've
been a [ __ ] for for most of my life and
so now i mean you're gonna talk about
we're all different maybe there's the
guy out there who needs to hear this
because he says i've been leading with
vulnerability all this time and i don't
get a second date because i i vomit out
my story on the on the first day and
maybe a qualifier in that would help him
to have longevity in that relationship
for that woman who wants a real life
human that's all i'm saying if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]
you